Thank you so much tie.
It's a great pleasure for me to come here to Google,
but also a special privilege to be introduced by dying.
I have a friend,
but also we have been constantly exchanging ideas.
And today I like to talk to you,
talk to you.
What about I view as the three frontiers of information technology for the
future of hunting,
computing,
artificial intelligence and blockchain,
but especially also the possible symbiosis among these three major trends.
I think in these days in the world,
there are many experts in each one of those,
uh,
subjects.
But I think the really exciting opportunity is possibly the conference or the
symbiosis among these three major trends of the future of the information
technology.
They may start with a story of a recent scientific discovery,
a recent discovery,
but he had a long history.
So a lot of great discoveries in science also relates to some deep changes in
philosophy.
We seem to live in a world of opposites,
a world of dualism.
We have,
whenever we have positive numbers,
we have negative numbers.
When we'll have credits,
were have deaths,
we have yin and Yang.
Good and evil angels and demons.
But in the natural world,
there's also a counterpart to these,
uh,
philosophy of the opposites or the duality.
So in 1928,
the great,
perhaps a one of the greatest to theoretical physicist of all time,
Paul Dirac was trying to unify a Einstein's theory of special relativity with
quantum mechanics.
In the process of doing so,
he was doing as a mathematical derivations.
He had to encounter a operation of square root.
And then he remembered from his high school days there,
the square root of nine is not just three,
because three times three is nine,
but also minus to be made because minus three times a minus three,
it's also nine.
So whenever you take a route,
you have to take both the positive and the negative route at that time was very
perplexing.
What that negative route meant.
And He,
uh,
actually one brilliant stroke of genius.
He predicted that for every matter in the world,
that's the opposite matter or the antiemetic.
And to when you visit Westminster Abbey,
you can try to find a pack,
a commemorating the famous at Iraq equation.
And teeing,
uh,
2012,
one of the most humbling experience in my life is to receive the poor rock and
metal.
So just I said,
whenever you take the square root two,
you have the positive branch and the negative branch.
And uh,
he brilliantly interpreted the mega negative branch to be a universal law of
nature there too.
For every particle there seemed the universe,
there's also a antiparticle except at a time,
uh,
everybody viewed this as a beautiful,
equation,
but to,
except at the time of 1928 where he made these a prediction,
there was simply no Animoto.
So for example,
the anti matter of the electron will be something that has a positive charge,
but at the same mess,
the Proton has the opposite charge to the electron,
but has 2000 times more dms as the ilecture.
So nobody believed teams.
Uh,
then,
you know what he said?
He said,
my equation is so beautiful,
you guys simply just go look for it.
And to people did,
and he was lucky.
And five years later in cosmic ray radiation,
it's very hard to naturally produce that on earth.
But in the cosmic ray radiation,
people are discovered antiemetic,
namely the positron,
which has exactly the same mass but the opposite charge of the lecture.
So I think this is the one of the greatest prediction of all humanity.
Something conceived of beauty also turn out to be true today.
We actually use these anti-matter in medical devices,
a famous medical imaging technique called pet scan,
positron emission tomography.
And it was actually based on these antiparticle,
the,
uh,
posit Trump.
It also captured the imagination of Hollywood.
So there's a famous novel and the movie of Davinci Code.
Many of you have read a book and saw the movie,
but there's also a sequel to it called angels and demons.
Also played by a,
also a book by Dan Prompt.
I also play by Tom Hanks.
Uh,
basically the novel depicts the epical epic struggle between,
between angels and demons,
cumulating in the and the hill Asian of particles and antiparticles.
So actually it's the highest,
uh,
information density one can possibly achieve anywhere in the universe.
If you have anti-matter and with matter,
the energy they release a is the most powerful there can ever be.
But it's also a fun analogy.
Just us.
We have Angio,
we have demon.
Whenever will have positive particle,
we have the opposite,
the antiparticle,
but human curiosity didn't stop there.
So after the rocks,
a prediction is viewed as one of the,
the upgraders,
the prediction of wartime.
Uh,
curiosity didn't stop there.
So there was a,
another great theoretical physicist,
but somewhat elusive,
uh,
during his time.
Uh,
my name is Tori,
my Iran,
and he asked the curious question,
could that be matter which denim hip and he matter,
or a particle which is its own anti particle or a particle which would not have
its own,
uh,
we're not have a antiparticle is its own anti particle.
Is that possible?
So he asked this question and he also wrote down a beautiful equation,
which described it,
but this time he was not so lucky.
Nobody believed him and nobody found it.
So,
uh,
he actually got very disappointed about that.
So ever since then it became a mystery in fundamental science.
So we have a in fundamental science and most wanted list for example at the list
included what is called a dot particle or Hicks Bozon.
But in 2012,
uh,
it was discovered in soon in the laboratory in Geneva.
There's also the gravitational wave,
uh,
Einstein was less likely then to rock the rock.
Only his prediction only took five years for it to be experimentally confirmed.
But Einstein's prediction of gravitational wave more than 100 year,
only two years ago it was discovered was an Einstein predicted or 100 years ago.
So there's such a list and to,
and to also something called the dark matter particle,
which we're still trying to find,
but also very much on the top of the list is this a very interesting concept of
Mirena Afirma,
which is a particle which does not have anti particle or is its own anti
particle,
but it's more mysterious maybe among all those,
uh,
on the most wanted list.
And maybe my runner for me is most mysterious because not only am I a runner,
Philomena has not been found.
And like I said,
he was very disappointed when nobody believed in his prediction and to,
he was Italian and he,
uh,
boarded a ferry from Palermo,
to,
uh,
from,
Naples to polemical,
but he never reappeared from that very right.
So you become a deep,
deep mystery and DCA is exactly the 80 year of his disappearance.
But we also have some good news to report even though he himself was never
found.
His particle now has been found.
And that's the highlight of my talk today.
So,
uh,
so then,
because he's in pre down the equation,
but he didn't tell people where to find it.
So that's why it took 80 years.
And so nobody knew where to find them.
But so my theory group has Stanford predicted where and how to find these
mysterious particle and seeing,
uh,
during,
the period of 2010 and 2015,
uh,
or theory group wrote three theoretical papers.
First one,
exactly to predict where actually quite surprisingly,
it's not too,
uh,
for these particles to be found in some huge accelerators.
But you could be in a tabletop kind of experiment,
very much like a semiconductor device.
People will usually use.
So it's a material called the topological insulator.
Diane already mentioned introduction,
something I discovered 10 years ago,
but they putting into it some magnetic dopants.
So the topological insulators can be something that business terror,
right?
And they,
you can putting some magnetic dopants,
uh,
which could be chromium.
And then on top of it you apply a superconductor.
So we predict that in this system you can find these mysterious my runner from
yet.
But that's not good enough.
Not only you have to predict where to find it,
but to what to measure in order to find it.
And they are,
I think a common sense can even guide us.
So somehow the regular particle,
it's like two sides of coin.
Whenever you have the upside,
you have the downside.
When they bill,
you have deposited particle,
you'll have to antiparticle associated was it.
But East Myranda particle is only,
uh,
only one site.
It is so many a particle,
but no antiparticle.
So in some vague sense,
it is half of a user particle.
So this concept of a half will be very,
very important.
In the later part of my talk about quantum computers.
So somehow these Myranda particle is half of a regular particle.
So,
but regular particle has some phenomena of their conductance,
like the resistance or conductance we usually measure can be context in units of
zero,
one,
two,
three and so on.
So they behave like introduce in a conversation a step.
So w we once had a Eureka moment that if the Mirena particle is in some sense
half of a regular particle,
then they should display some plateau at half integer steps,
namely at one half,
three half and so on and so forth.
So that became or prediction that in this system you can experimentally comes
trapped by what you measure is this one half step in last year in the close
collaboration with experimental colleagues at Ucla,
Uc Davis and UC Irvine.
So they exactly a constructed this system as we theoretically proposed and they
performed the measurement exactly according to our theoretical prediction.
And Lo and behold,
uh,
besides,
these integer step at one,
something a zero or UC,
there's a step at one half.
And this one half is a crucial idea that,
uh,
my Reiner particle being half of a regular particle,
it should display,
whereas regular particle display,
integer,
quantize step,
my runner portico should give you half quantized step.
So daddy is really the smoking gun and it was celebrated last year with the
publication in the Science magazine.
So in that very exciting moment,
I remember the famous and novel and a famous movie I saw about angels and
demons.
I procaine that it's a safe way discovered a paradise with only Angelus and no
So I call these the Injil particle.
So now what is,
is good for.
So today
or classical computers are already very,
very powerful,
but they are good at doing some things and not good at doing some other things.
So if I give you a very two very large numbers and to ask the computer to
multiply,
they do this in a split second Google couch.
You were maybe a Nano Nano second.
Uh,
but if you give a number and to ask the computer with a dead number,
factorized this into two other numbers,
giving the example,
for example,
15 is equal to three times five,
but 11 cannot be factorized as a product of two numbers.
The only thing you can do is to say 11 is one time,
say 11 which doesn't mean very much.
But then if I gave me a very,
very large number,
and if you want to ask whether the debt very large number of,
uh,
can be expressed just like 15 as the product of two other numbers,
or it is more like 11,
which cannot be expressed as a product to a numbers,
the computer and a classical computer will have a very,
very hard time to answer these questions.
The only way it can do is to do an exhaustive search.
It tries to divide these very large number by first by two,
then by three,
them a five by seven and so on and so forth.
And then it takes forever to,
to,
uh,
to do this exhaustive search.
So when you literally,
you think about maybe all of the most important computational provenance,
what we were like a computer to do with Google cloud,
with all the data.
What we would like to do is to find some optimal solutions of something.
So when we tried to find optimal solution,
we basically have to enumerate all possibilities computer,
all of them.
Maybe there's some function optimizing function associated with it,
and you try to find maybe the least path or biggest profit or something like
that.
But do you also have to do an exhaustive search and dead takes very,
very long time.
So that's why computer has a lot to advance.
But then enter the quantum world.
What is the mysterious world of the punctum world?
So if I have two slits and I use a classical [inaudible] and to randomly shoot
through these two slits,
then obviously a bullet either at one given time goes through the right or it
goes through the left and on the back of your two will see two blops,
one coming funded,
right?
And the other coming kind of left,
but not.
So if you try to shoot a elementary particles through the double slits,
so somehow,
uh,
on the background so you don't see two blobs associated with the right or one
associated with the left,
you actually observed rather intricate,
uh,
interference pattern.
And that pattern can only be explained if the particle went through double slits
at exactly the same time it went through both the right and the left at exactly
the same time.
If it didn't do so.
And if you knew which way it went,
it wouldn't need to these intricate interference pattern.
So somehow the quantum worlds,
the mysterious quantum world is parallel at one given time.
A particle is both going through the right and going through the left and then
people somehow started thinking there to this very difficult problem.
That computer classical computer has a very difficult time to solve.
Namely has to go through cereal knee.
It's a exhaustive search of all possibility.
Maybe it can be done by a quantum computer,
which is intrinsically parallel.
So basically then it can search through all these possibilities exactly at the
same time and give you one result in one step of computation.
So deadwood truly be wonderful and we'll increase the computational power in
such a tremendous way.
So,
but in order to have constructed such a quantum computer,
you first need to have the basic elementary unit,
which will be called a punctum bits or cubits.
So our classic Corbett as you have on your classical computer,
Eh,
one bit,
it's either zero or one,
but just like a quantum mechanical particle can go through a double slits at the
same time.
A quantum bit accubid somehow it's a linear super position between zero and one.
It's neither exactly zero,
no,
exactly one.
Somehow it lives in this mysterious superposition,
uh,
state,
between zero and one.
So in order to do a quantum computer unit necessary,
have to construct such a elementary cubit,
a quantum bit,
but to be in quantum mechanical is also very,
very fragile.
In the classical world,
if you are very curious to see why is it really zero is a really one,
you tried to observe it,
they immediately crash to zero one and you lose this mysterious content concept.
So therefore,
in all the most of the approaches that has been proposed to construct a quantum
computer,
uh,
it's,
has a lot and lots of errors.
These cubit is very,
very fragile and very unstable and uh,
it's very easily collapsed into a classical a cubit.
So therefore it's a,
it's a daunting number there to for wine,
useful logical cubit,
you have to use 10 to even perhaps 100 error correcting bit to correct,
uh,
one used for cubit.
And that obviously is very,
very,
very difficult to scale.
And that's why we don't yet have a truly functional quantum computer,
uh,
yet,
which can factories are very big number.
Now enter my a scientific discovery.
So we discovered this mysterious but very interesting angel particle,
which is half of a regular particle.
So then,
uh,
so it's a little bit,
complicated scientific diagram,
but somehow when you enter in with one cubit,
which is a regular particle,
it can be immediately split into two of these Maiorana thermia or this angel
particles.
So then each,
uh,
being half,
so one cubit you already think is the minimal thing that you can have,
but one cubit is not stored in to Andrew particles.
So just like one cubit entering here is partially start here and partially
stopped there.
Then if you have local perturbation,
it's very hard for local perturbation to destroy the global.
These two NGO particles together function as one cubit.
So it's very hard for local perturbation,
just destroyed this cubit and therefore it's a very,
very robust way of doing computation.
In fact,
in this experiment measurement,
what is happening is that this NGO particles that we see each other.
So if you have some lines,
and if you tried to Brayden,
that is kind of a digital operation.
If you either braided or you didn't.
Whereas in order most other approaches to quantum computing,
it's almost an analog computation.
You can make very easily make little errors.
But if you do what is called a topper logical operation of breeding,
then
then it's actually a very,
very robust,
so you might approach one.
Cubit is just one cubit.
You don't need error correcting cubits.
So this is a still,
uh,
after our discovery,
it's a still kind of a new approach.
So it's coming up,
but compared to other approaches,
which may already have many,
many cubits,
but a lot of them are serving as error,
correcting cubits to one useful cubit.
I believe our approach work eventually scale up much,
much faster because it's one to one.
So this is the first part of my talk about quantum computer.
But now let me switch to the second part of my talk,
which is about artificial intelligence.
When we look at the human history,
evs or it has a long,
uh,
kind of,
our earth.
And it took her a very long time for the most intelligent species,
uh,
to develop,
on earth and to took her maybe 3 million years of evolution.
But finally we became the dominating as species.
But now we actually faced with,
so our challenge may be a more intelligent species name.
The Ai could be some emerging,
but AI has been developing maybe since the 60s.
So why we suddenly have this,
uh,
such rapid increase in the progress of Ai.
So it's amazing.
Basically due to the conference of three major trends in computation
and one is the Morse law.
So the most law,
basically it's about computational power.
So it is,
uh,
a [inaudible],
the computational power doubles every 18 months according to the progress of the
most law.
So now most law is the facing some challenging,
that's the bad news.
But the good news is there too.
Maybe we'll have something so much more powerful when I then most law predicts,
namely,
we have most law has been a quantitative incremental increase even though it's
very,
very fast.
But quantum computer can be one content jump in the computation of power because
of this massive parallelism associated with quantum computing.
So on the horizon where he see both in the,
in terms of computational power,
we see those challenges to the classical most law as the device gets smaller and
smaller.
But we also see tremendous hope.
Maybe quantum computer can,
can arrive at a scene and to when you try to search,
uh,
among a optimization problem,
you can do one search for one rather than an exhaustive search in a serial
fashion.
So this is something on the horizon that could really a fundamentally be a game
changer.
But the other reason why artificial intelligence today is exploding is because
it was to arrival off the Internet and the Internet of things.
You provided a massive amounts of data
and machines need to learn and they learn only from epic data.
And the other is the rapid progress of the Ai Algorithm.
And to these,
uh,
use also one of the main reason,
for example,
the deep neural nets,
which is providing the main,
uh,
kind of engine behind the rapid growth.
So in the field of Ai,
we always ask these questions when,
what's some day AI surpass humans and what is the objective tests?
So,
uh,
where,
all totally amazed.
So to see the power is Google has made,
uh,
announced two years ago about deep minds having other goal which would beat a
human player in playing the game.
So anti was a very fortunate,
uh,
that,
our son,
uh,
Brian was also,
at,
uh,
working at the deep mind,
these kinds of projects at the same time at that time.
So,
uh,
when we asked this question,
so I'd like to revisit a question that we always have been asking,
namely the so called Turing test.
When is the objective tests that AI really past the human mind?
So touring propose the following tests a long time ago.
He says that if we have a human,
uh,
and then we're having a conversation with a,
something behind the curtain,
either another human or a AI machine.
And two,
if you talk for one long day and afterwards,
you cannot tell the difference whether it's a human behind or whether it's a
machine behind.
That may be the day when AI really reached a true human intelligence,
but I think it's not the objective test.
So,
first of all,
because the human brain,
it took a long,
long time to evolve.
And a lot of these,
uh,
human brain has a lot of irrational emotional components.
And maybe it can not be so imitated by the machine,
maybe also totally unnecessary for the machine to imitate every human
irrationality.
That's possible because one strategy is to talk to the machine totally
irrational way.
Maybe a ration of machine will be very hard to food the human too,
to,
to see that it's actually a human.
So,
but then what about the Google success at deepmind?
Off Our Alpha goal,
which is a game of human and it looks a little bit more objective,
but still it is a game invented by humans.
Why should uh,
intelligence test B based on,
again,
that's invented by human.
So what will be the most objective tests that AI really reached a human
intelligence.
So I like to have a proposal which could possibly replace the Turing test.
And then I ask to play a game of nature name.
They ask the machine to make a scientific discovery and before the humans do.
And maybe,
and then we can objectively use,
such as a prediction of a Mirena,
thermia gravitational wave,
some of the greatest to prediction of the human scientific mind and see if the
machine can make a prediction,
uh,
before the humans do.
And we were doing an objective experiment and verified the prediction.
We say dcis today when machine surpassed human intelligence.
So can we see whether this is possible or not?
So I am usually a theoretical physicist,
but I,
for the first time I wrote a paper on AI,
which was some be published.
So basic idea,
is that a,
that's pic.
So first of all,
we haven't made the progress of making a prediction that humans has not made.
But so we,
our ideas to be wine,
the history to say that if humanity,
is it still at a point where one great discovery hasn't yet been made and
whether the machine at the same level can make that a scientific discovery.
So we know some great predictions in theoretical physics such as gravitational
wave,
uh,
derog,
antiparticle and so on.
But maybe the greatest scientific achievements in chemistry is the Mandalay is
periodic table.
So Mandalay have looked at all the chemical compounds and he discovered in a
brilliant stroke of genius,
the organizing principle of the world,
namely,
that the order materials that we see can be reduced to,
uh,
elements,
but these elements organizing itself into a periodic table.
So at that time,
he,
uh,
there's only a limited number of elements discovered.
And once he organized them into a period of table,
he sees some hosts in the periodic table and he says,
oh,
these elements must be there.
You guys look for it.
So there was the brilliant a prediction.
And I think certainly I would rank these,
the greatest at scientific discovery in chemistry,
maybe of all humanity.
So the question we would like to ask ourself is that if we rewind history,
that,
uh,
we are in a stage that a periodic table has not yet been discovered,
but if we feed or the chemical compounds to a machine,
what machine be able to come up with the discovery of the periodic table?
So that's a,
maybe it's quite related to all the AI work that's going on at Google
and we actually core or a algorithm atom to Vec.
So once we see the name,
you immediately see that there must be a lot of connection to maybe all the work
you guys are doing here.
Namely there's uh,
all the Google translate or the natural language processing is based on a
algorithm caught word two VEC,
two map words into a vectorial form.
And once you woods until Victoria form,
you can understand,
uh,
the machine,
the vector actually in coats some semantic meaning of the word itself and they
can discover certain relationships.
So hardest word to Vec work basically tried to understand a word in the context
of other sentences.
If two words often occur together,
like king and Queen in one sentence,
the machine will understand maybe in vectorial space there somehow close to each
other.
So our idea is to borrow this kind of idea from the natural language processing
and try to see if it is possible to be used to make scientific discoveries.
So we're basically just like a Google here,
which a feed or the Corpus of texts into a machine using word two vec and then
discovered the meaning of the words and then do translation and so on so forth.
We basically feed in a total,
totally and supervised way or the list of all chemical compounds to the machine
and to see whether the machine can come up with an organizing principle.
And Lo and behold,
the machine or algorithm discovered the periodic table because the period table,
it can be viewed as nothing but a tool dimension.
No Victoria arrangements of all the elements.
But if you can do something like atom to Vac,
it will similarly match each element into some,
uh,
some,
vectorial form.
And the,
when you collapse these two two dimension,
you will exactly discovered the periodic table.
So for example,
uh,
let's see,
in a large corpus of text,
whenever you see king,
you see queen a lot,
the co occurrence a lot,
but a,
in chemistry,
whenever you see any ACO,
you see Kco a lot.
So you somehow the machine will understand in a and C and k may be very related
to each other.
So in vectorial space there must be close to each other.
So based on,
by borrowing the ideas for natural language processing,
we actually could organize in totally and supervised fashion.
The machine actually discovered the periodic table.
So I think we're getting into a very,
very exciting time that,
uh,
that a,
one of the greatest scientific discoveries can at least be replicated by a
machine discovery without any supervision whatsoever.
But once these algorithms start to work,
then we can use it to discover new materials and possibly be a user to discover
new drugs,
uh,
before the humans can do so.
Now let me move to the third topic of my,
uh,
of my talk today and namely about the blockchain.
And maybe some of you are already wondering what,
uh,
Ai and quantum computing and blockchain can possibly have anything in common
with each other.
So basically the Internet has always,
uh,
has provided a tremendous value,
in as a communication tool,
uh,
to,
to for all of us to communicate.
But then we have at some point,
we have to exchange values over the Internet.
But whenever we have to exchange value over the Internet,
we have to agree on the common standards of value.
So therefore,
the most important thing when you try to move to the next stage of the Internet
development,
possibly moving into the world of finance,
for example,
the key essence of finance is to have some consensus about the valley.
Uh,
the reason why we use goat's previously is because compared to something like an
apple,
a as a medium of exchange,
is because everyone can agree on what one ounce of gold actually means.
We can do position measurement to determine its content and quality,
but it's very hard to do it for one apple because there's so many different
kinds of apples.
So it's not suitable as a medium of exchange.
So therefore,
the key element of a medium of exchange is consensus.
So if I have very broad distribution,
uh,
about the value,
then it's not suitable to use as immediate of change.
If we all agree on the value reaching consensus,
then it is extremely valuable.
So the Internet taught us one very important thing is to an MD to do things in a
distributed fashion,
but you feel have a very distributed network.
How can they possibly agree on something?
So previously in human economy we always thought there has to be some
centralized entity,
which is trying to control a lot of it and get people to agree on some values.
But when you actually observe the natural world,
there is a way for the natural world to reach consensus.
So let me give you one example or the physics.
Uh,
for example,
uh,
where every day when you're woke up,
and walk towards your refrigerator to get a glass of milk or something,
people usually like to stick a magnet,
um,
their refrigerator.
So how does a magnet really worked?
So actually all materials consist of electrons.
Electron works like a compass.
It has a North Pole and there's hospital.
So electrons actually it works like a magnet,
but the most of the time they don't agree on the direction to point to.
So they all point in random directions and therefore globally macroscopically
they don't behave like a magnet.
But to the magnet that sticks on your refrigerator,
somehow miraculously,
a consensus has been reached.
Oh,
electrons decide to point in the same direction and that is happening without
any centralized entity telling you,
lecture us what to do.
Somehow there's a mechanism of a protocol of exchange.
Somehow they miraculously agreed to a 0.1 direction,
so details about as something very,
very profound about the net natural world to agree on something is what is
called the low entropy state and to be disordered is in the high entropy state.
The natural trend of the world is to gradually,
always the entropy has to increase over time.
The world always becomes more and more disordered,
but somehow in a subsystem you can actually reach hung high consensus,
reduce entropy,
but then necessary has to,
there has to be a cost.
You have to dump the extra entropy somewhere else.
So it's a consensus can't happen in some self organized a distributed way,
but there has to be a cost associated with it.
That seems consensus is a state of low entropy.
You have to dump the extra entropy somewhere else.
That's icing kiss the fundamental explanation of why blockchain is working.
So blockchain has a distributed to the world of computers and the only approach
to have managing a distributed system of computers is to ask whether there's
some centralized master agritourism,
deterministic algorithm possible,
which will coordinate and and uh,
direct or these distributed computers even though some of them have very long
latency,
very broad distribution of latency and someone of them can even be hacked and
behave maliciously,
whether they're still in all these circumstances,
uh,
master deterministic algorithm possible to tell all these computers exactly what
to do and reach consensus.
Then there's a famous result in computer science code,
the Fisher Lynch Patterson,
which actually is a no go result,
which says such a master deterministic algorithm is not possible.
So this actually is a very reminds me of central result of physics.
Namely the entropy always have to increase.
You have such kind of a master algorithm exists.
Actually we have a name for it.
It's called Maxwell's demon.
So somehow this demon has very high intelligence.
For example,
if you have a component of our gas and you have a war dividing between them and
you have a little hole,
the Maxwell's demon,
when it sees a high energy particle funded the left,
it opens the shutter ladies through and to low energy particle coming through
and the closest the shadow and doesn't it.
So then if this demon can do all this,
choreograph a in a efficient way,
then little bit later,
these sites where be much harder than this site and then you can extra some work
to it.
So such centralized entity to coordinate,
we're really,
uh,
be able to extract energy out of nowhere.
And this obviously is not possible.
So I like to make the analogy of the Fisher Lynch.
Patterson's theory was the concept of the Maxwell Demon.
None of them are possible.
The master algorithm is not possible.
And to Maxwell demon is not possible.
So what's the solution?
The solution is provided by the blockchain.
So if you want the entire distributed Internet to agree on some temporal order,
which is the most crucial thing for financial transactions,
which transaction happened first?
Which transaction happens later?
You want to order machines to vote,
but voting at a cost by solving what is called a hash puzzle.
Only those machine can,
which can solve a hash puzzle,
which is very difficult to solve,
but very easy to verify.
Then once a machine soft these hash puzzle,
every machine will agree that yes,
this is true and we agree on this temporal order.
So it's such to Shasta Algorithm and it's,
uh,
actually requires energy to compute and to reach these hash puzzle.
So therefore in the self organized blockchain consensus mechanism,
we reach consensus,
namely in a state of low entropy,
but we dumped extra entropy somewhere else.
Uh,
Serrada computation of the hash puzzle.
And that is very similar to what's happening the physical world.
Namely,
we can in principle reach the state of consensus of low entropy provided if we
dump extra entropy's somewhere else.
So I really think this is really one of the most brilliant invention of in human
history.
Somehow we can have a natural and objective mechanism in the distributed world
to reach consensus,
but there's a cost to it.
Then they have to do this mining work.
So that the extra entropy can be dumped somewhere else.
So once we have this consensus mechanism,
I think this offers a great new opportunity,
new kind of a symbiosis between blockchain and AI.
So I talked about Aib and conference,
a major conference of three major trends.
I eluded to,
uh,
to the computational power,
most law and then possibly quantum computers.
I also talk about some new inventions in the algorithm,
but to what AI needs the most is to have data so that AI can learn.
But right now our data are concentrated as centralized platforms.
So there's very little incentive for individuals to contribute data because they
basically get nothing in return and maybe their privacy could even be violated.
So I envisioned the future of the world where the ownership of that data,
it should be completely be returned to the individuals.
So all my personal data or my behavior data on my online data,
on my genomics data or my medical records,
everything should be owned by the individual and the privacy should be
completely protected.
But then you'll say,
wow.
Then CalCom machine,
possibly learning this thing,
if everybody keeps their secret private.
And there is a beautiful thing called privacy preserving computation and that
will make it possible to have a data marketplace.
So I,
first off,
we're protected all my privacy data,
but I can leak information out one bit at a time.
Totally at mind control.
And a such a world will be a data marketplace,
the individually,
so it's a peer to peer marketplace,
whereas individually under their private data and then there can be a bidding
and sending a process,
a very selectively control by performing privacy,
preserving data marketplace.
So such a future world of a,
of a marketplace,
uh,
based on one thing support,
which I caught in math,
we trust.
Uh,
and that's is a possible with that it's a,
it that you can still preserve privacy,
uh,
but still maintain a and but still can do a computation that,
only leaks out very,
very selectively,
one in piece of inflammation at a time.
So the famous province is called the secure multiparty computation or a
millionaire province.
So obviously private wealth is very,
very private.
So people don't like to reveal.
But yeah,
it could be so happened that 2 million years.
Want to compare how we switcher but without revealing to each other.
If they review to each other,
the wells,
they have obviously a you there we'll find out,
but leaks too much privacy data.
But there's a computation or protocol called Yas Yas Cobbold circuit that they
can exchange protocol in the end of the day,
they only find out one bit of information.
Now May,
who is Richard without revealing anything,
there's a idea of a differential privacy,
namely adding noise to a private data so that they don't become individually
identifiable.
But if I want to conduct a collective survey,
I can add noise in such a way that in the statistical aggregate the noise will
cancel out.
So the statistical information is completely accurate.
But no,
not much.
Individual private data has been leaked because there's so enough noise that
individually identifiable information is not there.
But,
uh,
the overall,
overall,
uh,
statistical information still accurate.
And then there's also the idea of zero knowledge proof.
I can prove to you,
for example,
that I solved a very difficult game,
let's say the pseudo cocaine,
but I want to only give you one bit of information.
Emily,
I softer game,
but I don't want to review you.
My entire solution.
I want you to keep on trying and Carter and this is also possible through the
zero knowledge proof.
So there's literally a world where mathematics,
we're enter economics in a very central way,
uh,
in making a data marketplace possible so that way all of us were owned or
individual data and then uh,
uh,
Google cloud and all these entities then can compute,
in a centralized,
eh,
they can compute useful statistical information without revealing Roy,
without in having us to read a review of these privacy dad.
So I really think about this world where both AI and blockchain combined can do
great social good in this new era of crypto economic size based on,
in math with trust.
Because the way you really think about what's the problem with our society today
is because there's this,
we're a nation against minority and that is a fundamental of our society.
But when you really think about AI learning,
let's say if my AI algorithm is already a working accurately in 90% of the time,
but I want some extra data so that I can go off on 90% to 99%,
that that I is not yet another kind of data which looks very similar to all the
previous data I have seen.
I want data,
which is called to have high mutual entropy,
namely the data that's most distinct.
And that by definition is own by the minority.
But they,
in such a data marketplace,
I will bid the highest for those data,
which most,
uh,
you know,
minority.
So then the economic incentive structure would be aligned.
Our society will be value the minority to most,
uh,
and that's exactly what we need to do social goods.
So finally,
there's a vision that the ugly duckling can somehow become a beautiful swan
because the ugly duckling is not ugly.
It's different.
But now a difference will be valued the most minorities in these fear that a
market place will not be discriminated against.
So I'd really see these wonderful new worlds in a conference of three major
trends,
quantum computing,
AI and blockchain.
But I also see myself being coming from academia and open in interactions with,
uh,
Pontiac seeing industry.
I will really can enter a new world where the latest,
the scientific idea,
it's really,
really fascinating and totally amazing.
Dentist mathematical concepts was purely invented by mathematicians in abstract
could turn out to be so useful.
So something like number theory,
uh,
everyday when we conduct a transaction using http s uses number theory in the
most essential way.
So this is the wonderful new world where collaboration with academia in the
industry can really lead to great progress.
Uh,
uh,
as I say,
it's the greatest opportunity,
uh,
of making progress is oftentimes see a conference of some major trends,
before.
And anyone who are desk in their specialized area put in,
see the overall picture and tie,
really seen that the symbiosis among these three major trends will be the
defining characteristic of the future of inflammation technology.
Thank you.
Could I entertain some questions?
So you've talked about the consensus and how proof of work systems achieve a gun
sense despite this to be a deacon like these it will be,
yeah.
How does it,
how best start working before statements?
Thank you.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I actually,
I think in the end of the day they should always be some tradeoffs.
So I think can find them as a fan.
I see the future of the blockchain world and to those,
uh,
Krypto currency were happening in assumption what light?
Well,
what we're heavy in the current world,
that kind of war,
we'll have m zero m one m two different layers.
So I believe at the most fundamental layer,
a universal currency should be completely based on proof of work because then
the entropy that you dump is extreme.
It's a totally transparent,
not only has to be there,
but there's also totally transparent.
I think at the most basic and fundamental layer,
poof,
off state will not work because there's so much possibility of collusion that
you can lose something I'm chain,
but gain something,
uh,
off chain or you can be bribery and so on.
So I think where the,
what the truly exciting thing about the blockchain world is that at the most
fundamental layer,
that can be something that's totally objective and only connects to the natural
world named the energy and not so much about proof of stake,
which a human irrationality can get involved.
But I came very well.
You Imagine I'm the higher layers then they will prove I wrote.
But the most fundamental layer such like m one or m zero,
it should be,
uh,
completely robust.
And I still think the proof of work or this is something,
uh,
another approach which is called proof of space,
time proof office space,
which is based on storage.
And that's,
I think it's also,
it's a pong certifiable physical resources,
uh,
I think get the most,
basically you're a human things to them being involved,
but maybe at a higher layers.
Can you elaborate on that?
Watching?
So financial client computing requires Metairie transformations and it's not,
it's something that should be reversible.
I'm like ashes.
Yeah.
So I mostly,
I think about a hundred computing may be useful for AI as a search algorithms.
So a one algorithm for,
so all these are also happening.
So one of the most interesting,
uh,
approach to AI is the king,
right?
Jen?
Every tiff at rosary and networks.
So I don't mean this is three trends.
I'll always necessarily have to work together.
They can actually leads to progress by competing with each other.
So in one aspect of quantum computing and blockchain and somewhat competing with
each other because I loved her to quit or encoding algorithm could be broken by
plankton.
But on the other hand,
I also see that a quantum can help AI in doing the most efficient search.
And that's what also what AI needs to do,
right?
So this relationship is very much like a symbiosis in the ecosystem.
There's both competition and collaboration.
Yeah.
We can not just use our human will to decade.
They will always do the same thing.
They,
I think in the process of competition,
they will all become stronger.
You mentioned a universal currency or n zero.
Yeah.
I'm curious.
I know your theoretical physicists,
but an execution to that.
When we think about an iPhone,
for example,
my iPhone seven talks to the iPhone six die from five,
but there's a metal layer of consensus to be reached that's like,
I actually agree into this distributed system.
Yeah.
Curly and Crypto,
there's many fragmented pools of liquidity,
quote unquote.
So how,
how do you bridge that
gap between where we are now in these?
So I think could have,
for example,
delegation should be changed.
The bitcoin blockchain lightening network very much fits to this framework off m
one and two.
Uh,
so at the,
basically you're,
the blockchain is completely objective,
be some proof of work,
uh,
and to dcis.
The church trait would reach the most universal consensus among parties,
which I totally don't know each other.
And then you'd still need to trance out.
But when you really think about business transaction,
maybe 12 us to already have been working very well as partners in the last 10
years.
So why should we still use treating each other as a,
as a totally strangers?
So what we can do is we enter into each other a state channel by putting our
collaborators on the blockchain.
But we keep on doing very,
very fast trading,
but we still saddle once a month.
So this is I think exactly like the relationship between m zero m one m two,
the relationship between lightening and Bitcoin is like the relationship between
m zero and one.
So,
uh,
when you got above every layer,
so there's should be,
it's a less robust but we'll be more efficient.
But the trade off comes from our history that were already had a history of
trust.
But if you have business partners,
they already,
someone know each other.
They don't absolutely have to use the most universal robust,
uh,
layer.
They can establish a higher layer where they sacrifice some universality.
But uh,
in exchange for efficiency,
yes.
Particle
positive or negative.
Yeah.
So it's a half or two bits,
it sounds like identity and I'm an astronaut,
bro.
Ring or field,
right.
Identity animate.
You know,
when a,
again,
it itself stays at the same identity and I know that more precise analogy,
it's like a complex number can be expressing in terms of tool,
real numbers.
So the,
so a complex number,
he's like a particle.
The complex conjugate is like the antiparticle,
but if you have the real number,
the complex conjugate is the same as itself.
Okay.
So,
so,
so the NGO particle is more like a real number.
I see.
How would you now when you think of like on a yet forces yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
One would be new to animate whether we would be the NGO.
Yeah.
So,
so yeah.
Uh,
well I think the analogy is just to say that that uh,
so here,
this one incoming quantum cubit,
but actual computation before you do actual computation,
you're splitting them.
And by splitting them,
they're already kind of become nonlocal.
They're entangled but a classical noise,
it's not entangled.
So it's impossible to destroy it using classical noise.
So that's why topological quantum computer can be so much more robust.
Yes.
Combining a couple of the themes of your talk,
if a,
for able to
harness the power of quantum competing and if we're able to then secure our data
through,
uh,
you know,
privacy and encrypted ways of being able to share it.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm wondering how you see the future of Google because that seems like a truly
existential threat.
If anyone can spin up a quantum computer that can do extremely efficient
parallel search.
Yeah.
And then they can harness everyone's data.
My way is to not resist changes but to embrace change.
Right,
right,
right.
So how do you see,
for example,
the world?
Yeah,
yeah.
Actually,
uh,
I have an answer to these.
Okay.
So,
uh,
in,
in this way,
uh,
actually we can do the following construct data.
So for example,
my private data,
and I want to store it in a secure way,
but still be possible to do some computation.
So we know Google cloud competes with Amazon cloud.
So what we can do is that,
um,
the Amazon cloud,
I still completely random numbers,
but on the Google Cloud,
I store my inflammation plus the vending information.
I Still Amazon cloud.
So if I really can't assume this,
these two entities are really competing very hard.
Maybe there's no collusion and there there's no way they will secretly the
exchange.
But then you can use the protocol off secure multiparty computation to do a
computation which gets only one result without revealing any details.
So in this world,
centralized entity still is useful.
But in order for this to work,
you have to assume that are competing but not colluding.
Hi,
I'm just wondering,
the youth of term entropy is interesting because it seemed to be this mysterious
thing,
but it's also very precise that in thermodynamics you'll never logarithm term
in,
um,
in classical thermodynamics and then you have clash.
And then with information,
so we,
we have an entropy and then you may get analogy,
you think energy,
it's,
that kind of reminds me of like I'm some sort of free energy.
Yeah.
And you can see exactly,
yeah.
So,
so I think the blockchain world is exactly extracting,
extracting some free energy out of it.
So,
so,
so yeah,
basically you're achieving something,
but whatever you achieve the total amount of energy to use useful amount,
uh,
it's only the energy you spent minus the entropy that you have to waste.
So the subtract.
And so a lot of you actually today still see a lot of white papers.
They claim to do miraculous things.
And this kind of white papers reminds me of the proposals in the 18th century
about the pitcher.
Mobili
um,
I'm just,
I'm wondering,
can you extrapolate that now that you further then you need a temperature term
for the Collegian to work?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Actually the temperature of course,
a very natural lean if when Emily you have are conserved quantity as such as a
conservation of energy,
uh,
the temperature concept,
naturally a boss because anytime you have a rendering but conservative system,
uh,
it's the most generic what is called a Boltzmann distribution.
So the entropy,
the temperature comes in naturally,
but I think include lit.
Why I get so excited about this is the,
for the first time I see a convergence between social science and natural
science.
That's team provides an anchor for the social scientific world named at the
front.
So in my idea for m zero m one m two,
the fundamental anchor is not anchored on natural science.
We can precisely see the entropy.
It's wasted.
So we can see why it's consensus is reached and then you can build a more human
things on top of it.
But then most basic layer is now common bitching situ and the natural science
and fundamentally reduces to NV energy entropy aim formation.
Thanks.
Thanks so much for your time.
Um,
so I think you were talking to,
were saying that you can see this first layer of one block chain and then
further layers built on top of that.
Um,
so what do you think of the various projects or companies are trying to build
their own blockchain?
And how does that relate to her talks,
did you think?
I think,
uh,
I,
yeah,
so there has to be some unique thing that you provide.
So a Bra,
a Bitcoin blockchain,
and you sitting,
I'd really different.
So,
uh,
because as a fundamental layer of trust you after don't want universal Turing
machine because it can be maybe hacked,
but then you have to do some more transactions on top of it and then you see
random look,
some more natural.
So the evolution of the blockchain world will emulate the evolution of
biological species.
Uh,
you see fall king,
you see different species.
Uh,
if they fought long enough,
maybe they become a different species,
but there's always something fundamental,
namely or biological beings are based ourselves.
So this kind of basic contracts or not change,
but to some organization,
the different organisms at different organizations have different cells that may
change.
Yes.
Thank you for your time.
So my question is when do you think quantum computing would be in the
application?
Uh,
like after your findings and research and vanities in the application.
Do you think it's going to be in the hands of,
on the big certain companies or it's with its scale?
Yeah,
I think so.
So yeah,
so I think a quantum computing research most ideally should be done in open
environment.
Uh,
I think because,
uh,
yeah,
then you just make these statements because I know a lot of companies are
trying,
but the very nature of company training is they have to protect shareholder
anxious.
They have to protect the secret but to,
for something so powerful,
uh,
and its implication for humanity.
So I know that I think it should be best conducted team open university
research.
Sure.
And is exactly what I'm
doing.
So my approach to quantum computer,
I have many,
many temptations to do a company.
I'll quantum computers,
but I'd resisted that
with or without my,
you mentioned,
I think if you use this old way of uh,
if you use this way of train it will take a long,
long time.
Can you just imagine for one useful cubit you'd need to 70 cubic to the it
icing.
It wouldn't scale,
but with this approach you were scale.
Okay.
I think we wrap up,
I'm going to ask one last question.
Okay.
About your angel of Hermione,
does it change any other requirements of quantum computing?
Like such as absolute zero temperature?
No,
no,
no.
It's just still operates at all.
Most proposals,
I'll pray to low temperature,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
But a approach could work at room temperature if a room temperature
superconductors discovered,
but that hasn't been discovered yet.
But we,
we,
she had in mind that maybe for some very,
very hot computer station,
if you will,
there's really a qualitative improvement.
We can just call it to look in pitch.
Okay.
Well thank you so much.
[inaudible].